un peu énigmatique très très calme il
n'y a pas un bruit
juste un petit nuage de vapeur d'eau
gelée surtout vu du côté esthétique
je trouve qu'elle est très belle
correspond bien à notre époque si tu
cathédrale en fin de compte il est donc
gelé photographié sous toutes les
coutures j'ai fais vraiment autour de
retour dans son atelier grâce aux images
qu'il a en tête
il va mettre la centrale nucléaire sur
une toile et la transcender bateaux à
quai port aux fourneaux silo à grains
usines les paysages industriels ont
toujours inspiré l'artiste
il aime larchitecture de cellules c'est
génial ensemble de lignes de
perspectives parce que ça dépend aussi
beaucoup du cadrage que je vais faire au
départ que je ne vais pas tout prendre
le paysage mais quand on regarde comme
ça quand on se fait une fenêtre
il ya un moment donné où ça fait un
tableau comme s'il ya une organisation
de ligne 2
de couleur d'agencement des formes voilà
qui à un moment donné se passe bien quoi
voilà le tableau une fois que ça c'est
un magazine et le tableau est
pratiquement fait qu'il n'ya plus qu'à
peindre à faire
[Musique]
beaucoup de silence dans sa peinture
le silence de l'humain qui est qui est
derrière dans les petites lumières des
porcs dans une voiture rouillé dans une
cheminée qui fument la l'humain et la
haie mais c'est toujours silencieux des
discrets il ya une élégance aussi dans
son travail et beaucoup de poésie noir
argenté ou bien rouge après le coucher
du soleil
l'artiste pas le fleuve à toutes les
époques de l'année il pose sur la loire
un regard particulier à la fois réaliste
et imaginaire